Actors can play superheroes, wizards, and
even gods, so sometimes it’s easy to forget
that they’re just human beings.
And like everyone else, the most famous faces
in Hollywood are prone to making their fair
share of mistakes.
As the old saying goes, nobody’s perfect,
and numerous stars have had plenty of run-ins
with the law during their lifetimes.
It’s true that some of them managed to turn
things around after their incidents, but that
still doesn’t change what they did.
Here are 10 famous actors who committed real
life crimes.
Lindsay Lohan
After Mean Girls, Lohan seemed destined to
become the hottest starlet in the industry,
but the wheels came off pretty quickly and
her downward spiral ruined her career.
That’s in large part due to her extensive
rap sheet that includes multiple DUI arrests,
drug abuse, and more than one stint in jail.
Lohan has also been to rehab on several occasions
and was frequently on probation.
May 2015 became the first time in 8 years
the actress was probation free, after she
completed community service from a reckless
driving charge.
She may not be able to turn her career around,
but hopefully Lohan can get her life in order.
Charlie Sheen
The infamous bad boy made all sorts of headlines
for his wild antics in 2011, but he was getting
into trouble well before then.
On Christmas Day 2009, Sheen was arrested
for assaulting his third wife, Brooke Mueller.
She claimed that Sheen had pinned her down
in bed and held a knife to her throat.
The actor was released on bail later that
same day.
He was later charged with felony menacing,
third degree assault and criminal mischief.
As part of a plea bargain to dismiss other
charges, Sheen pled guilty to misdemeanor
assault and spent a month in rehab and on
probation, in addition to attending anger
management courses.
Hugh Grant
Hugh Grant is a charming and likable lead
in many romantic comedies, playing a man that
many women would want to spend the rest of
their life with.
But his biggest fans may be shocked to hear
about the time Grant was arrested for soliciting
prostitution.
While promoting his movie Nine Months, the
actor was found engaging in oral sex in public.
He was fined $1,180, placed on two years summary
probation, and had to attend an AIDS educational
program.
Shortly after, Grant was quizzed about the
incident on The Tonight Show, saying, “I
did a bad thing.”
Fortunately for him, the public forgave him
and he’s done very well for a number of
years.
O.J. Simpson
The football Hall of Famer turned Naked Gun
star is infamous for the 1994 murder trial
where he was acquitted of charges, but Simpson
couldn’t outrun the law in 2007.
He was arrested for robbing a Las Vegas casino.
Simpson admitted to committing the crime,
saying he led a group to steal sports memorabilia
because the items belonged – and were stolen
from – him.
In 2008, Simpson was sentenced to 33 years
in prison, with a minimum of nine without
parole.
He did a number of great things throughout
his multi-faceted career and earned legions
of fans, so it’s sad that he wasn’t able
to stay on the straight path.
Wesley Snipes
Tax season is a grind for all of us, and no
matter how much we hate it, we have to pay
Uncle Sam when he comes knocking.
No matter how hard one tries, there’s no
way to buck the system and the IRS will catch
anyone who tries to slip past them.
Blade star Wesley Snipes was convicted of
tax fraud in 2006, making $23 million for
himself by falsifying documents prior to his
arrest.
In 2008, he was sentenced to three years in
prison for failure to pay his income taxes.
He served from 2010-2013 and resumed his acting
career by appearing in The Expendables 3 one
year later.
Hopefully he knows now to visit H&R Block
before April 15.
Mickey Rourke
Rourke has had a decades-long acting career
that includes roles in popular films such
as The Wrestler and Iron Man 2.
But before he was on the screen, Rourke spent
his time in the ring as an amateur boxer.
During this time, the future actor was arrested
in 1994, accused of abusing his then-wife
Carrie Otis.
The charges were later dropped.
Rourke was also arrested in 2007 for DUI.
He has a checkered past, but Rourke revived
his career recently, crediting a newfound
commitment to religious faith for steering
him on the right course.
His fans are hoping he’s put his problems
behind him and he can keep making movies.
Winona Ryder
While not as egregious a crime as others on
this list, shoplifting is still against the
law and can have serious penalties.
Actress Winona Ryder learned this the hard
way in 2001 when she was arrested in Beverly
Hills, accused of stealing $5,500 worth of
designer clothes and accessories.
Ryder agreed to pay to Civil Demands to fully
reimburse the store.
During a trial associated to the charges,
Ryder was ultimately convicted of grand theft,
shoplifting, and vandalism.
She was sentenced to three years probation,
480 hours of community service, and had to
pay $3,700 in fines.
Ryder said she was depressed during the incident,
but she’s back on top now as a standout
on Netflix’s series Stranger Things.
Will Smith
The Fresh Prince of Bel Air is so charming
and charismatic, it’s difficult to envision
him ever being in the wrong, but that wasn’t
the case in 1989.
Smith was arrested and charged with aggravated
assault, reckless endangerment, simple assault,
and criminal conspiracy for his involvement
in an altercation that almost left record
promoter William Hendricks blind.
Smith claims he was innocent, saying in a
2005 interview that the incident was not his
fault.
According to him, “One of my buddies beat
up this dude, and I was there.
That’s my story and I’m sticking to it.”
It’s a non-issue now, as Smith remains one
of the top draws in Hollywood.
Matthew Broderick
It’s a well-known story by now.
In 1987, Matthew Broderick was vacationing
in Ireland with Jennifer Grey, who he met
during filming Ferris Bueller’s Day Off.
In his rental car, the actor forgot he was
in a different country and was driving on
the wrong side of the road.
He collided head on with another vehicle,
which led to a truly upsetting tragedy.
The two people in the other car did not survive
the crash.
Broderick got away with numerous injuries
and Grey suffered whiplash.
Broderick faced up to five years in prison,
but the charges were reduced to careless driving
with a $175 fine.
The family of the victims called it a travesty
of justice.
Lane Garrison
Garrison is best known for his role on the
TV series Prison Break, where he appeared
in 17 episodes as the character Tweener.
His time on the show ended in 2007, right
when the actor was sentenced to 40 months
in jail.
In 2006, Garrison pled guilty to vehicular
manslaughter, as well as providing alcohol
to a minor as he drove with cocaine and alcohol
in his system.
The passenger of his car didn’t survive
a crash Garrison caused.
Garrison was released in April 2009.
Tweener was killed in season 2 of Prison Break,
so Garrison can’t return for the followup
series.
He can be seen in the 2016 miniseries Roots.
Those are just some of the actors who have
committed real-life crimes.
Which ones did we miss?
Let us know in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more videos.